Пані та панове!
Вітаю всіх вас і хочу одразу усунути одну несправедливість.
Ця панель конференції називається David on the Dnipro.
Я бачу в цьому справедливу повагу до України й усього, що роблять наші люди.
Однак цього року рішучість була проявлена на різних берегах. І не лише Дніпра.
Шпрее й Сена, Темза й Потомак, Вісла і Тибр: Давид зараз – це всі ми, це вільний світ.
Це кожна й кожен, хто відчув, що не залишається альтернативи,
окрім як здолати Голіафа, який прийшов зруйнувати наше життя.
Бути Давидом – це боротись. І ми боремося.
Бути Давидом – це мати пращу, щоб перемогти.
Ми поки що не маємо David's Sling з Ізраїлю. Вірю, що тимчасово.
Але зараз я хочу подякувати за потужну підтримку та зброю.
Дякую Олафу й Еммануелю, які зі мною на цій панелі,
дякую всім нашим партнерам, які присутні й представлені сьогодні тут, у Мюнхені.
США, Британії, всім країнам ЄС і всього світу.
Я вдячний усім, хто дає українському Давиду пращу, завдяки якій російський Голіаф уже похитнувся. Дякую.
Ми бачили це торік. І він неминуче впаде. Вже цього року!
Ми можемо це зробити. Усі разом, як Давид.
Ми можемо зробити так, щоб нашій перемозі не було альтернативи.
Але тоді не має бути альтернативи й нашій із вами рішучості.
Рішучості всіх нас: на Дніпрі й на Шпрее, на Сені й на Темзі, на Потомаку й на Віслі, на Тибрі й на Дунаї, і на Йордані,
і в кожній частині світу, де свободу цінують більше, ніж милість тирана.
Торік, коли я був тут, у Мюнхені, на конференції, я шукав таку загальну рішучість.
Україна чітко говорила світу: ми боротимемося за себе, якщо Росія піде повномасштабною війною.
Я хотів почути від світу: Україно, ми будемо з тобою.
На жаль, я почув це не одразу, а вже після того, як ударили російські ракети.
Вже після того, як пішли російські танкові колони.
Вже після того, як Путін знищив усі альтернативи, залишивши лише одну: хто переможе? Він чи ми?
Насправді ви вже дали відповідь назвою цієї панелі конференції.
Голіаф не має шансів. Але, на жаль, має потенціал.
На жаль, торгуючи зі світом, пробує купувати собі час для агресії.
На жаль, може знищити ще багато життів.
Ось чому ми маємо поспішати. Нам потрібна швидкість.
Швидкість наших домовленостей. Швидкість постачання для посилення нашої пращі.
Швидкість рішень для обмеження російського потенціалу.
Швидкості немає альтернативи. Бо швидкість зараз – це те, від чого залежить життя.
Зволікання завжди було і є помилкою.
Поки ми зараз домовляємось, як посилити нашу оборону сучасними танками,
Кремль думає, як задушити ще Молдову.
Поки ми переконуємо, що Україні потрібна сучасна бойова авіація, Кремль уже переконав іранський режим.
Як результат – не лише вбивчі іранські дрони в українському небі.
Але й також щось, чим Кремль заплатив за це.
Чи впевнені ви, що це лише гроші? Чи, може, світ зіткнеться зі «збагаченим іранським режимом»?
І якою мірою – 90%, 92% чи 100%?
Я впевнений, що ніхто з нас не хоче, щоб регіон Близького Сходу та Перської затоки відчув це на собі.
Поки ми витрачаємо тижні на погодження нових санкцій проти Росії,
держава-терорист шукає шлях, як адаптуватися до вже впроваджених обмежень –
через паралельний імпорт, тіньовий флот танкерів тощо.
Де ми побачимо вплив цього незаконного прибутку Росії?
У намаганнях корумпувати ваші політичні системи та міжнародні інституції.
У спробах дестабілізації вашого суспільного життя й у кампаніях дезінформації проти ваших людей.
В ескалаціях у тих регіонах, які чутливі для вас.
Що очікує, наприклад, на Лівію, Малі чи Центральноафриканську Республіку,
поки Москва має силу? Що очікує Сирію?
Нічого хорошого. Як і багато інших народів. А отже, і вам не буде спокою.
А отже, справа не лише в Україні. Справа в тому, що Голіаф повинен програти.
Жодної альтернативи цьому немає!
Бо Кремль здатен зламати безпеку у мир усіх, хто представлений зараз тут, у Мюнхені.
Зволікання світу – це ресурс, від якого живиться путінська диктатура. Так було роками.
Що довше тягнулась дискусія про розширення Євросоюзу,
то більше деструктиву привносив Кремль у тодішню «сіру зону» між Євросоюзом і Росією.
Що голосніше говорилося, що треба почекати, перш ніж Україні дадуть увійти у «відкриті» двері НАТО,
то агресивнішою ставала російська політика.
Що довше тривало мовчання щодо Криму в глобальному порядку денному,
то більш енергійним ставав російський реваншизм.
Що більше світ сперечався, які санкції й коли запроваджувати проти Росії,
то нахабнішими ставали амбіції Кремля.
Що довше ми в Україні, у Європі й світі не мали єдності, то більше ілюзій було в Росії.
Зараз усе це виправляється.
Як і торік, зараз я пропоную діяти негайно.
Але, на відміну від того року, зараз у мене є максимально переконливий аргумент – це наші здобутки.
Чи можемо стримувати російські удари? Так.
Чи можемо ми дати захист містам від російських ракет? Безперечно.
Чи можемо ми звільняти нашу землю? 1891 доказ є цьому.
Саме стільки міст, містечок і сіл нам вдалося звільнити від російської окупації.
Чи можемо ми повернути безпеку в Чорному морі, а отже, продовольчу безпеку світу?
Чорноморська зернова ініціатива й гуманітарна ініціатива Grain from Ukraine переконливі.
Чи настав час Україні бути у Європі повноправно?
Більшість європейців підтримує членство для України.
Ми вже здобули статус кандидата на вступ.
Ми вже готуємося розпочати переговори щодо членства.
Ми вже об’єднані з європейською економікою, логістикою та енергетикою.
Українській перемозі немає альтернативи.
Україні у Євросоюзі немає альтернативи.
Україні в НАТО немає альтернативи.
Нашій з вами єдності немає альтернативи.
А отже, немає й не може бути альтернативи тому, щоб повністю звільнитися від російської агресії.
Звільнити землю й людей.
Бо кожне місто й село, що залишаються в окупації, – це люди, які залишаються в неволі.
Чи можуть люди бути предметом компромісу? Ні.
Треба звільнити Україну та Європу.
Бо коли російська зброя стріляє в нас, її приціли вже наведені й на наших сусідів.
Чи може Європа бути предметом компромісу? Ні.
Треба звільнити від російського агресивного потенціалу кожну міжнародну інституцію
й кожну галузь світової економіки.
Бо лише тоді зʼявиться шанс для свободи пройти через наш кордон далі на схід.
Чи може свобода бути предметом компромісу? Ні. І це «ні» тверде, як камінь.
Впевнений, що можемо здобути перемогу не лише над Путіним,
а й над путіними – над путіними в Росії і в решті світу.
Хіба це не буде доказом сили ідеї свободи? Точно буде.
Пані та панове!
Рішучість ніколи не буває абстрактною.
Давид здолав Голіафа не силою розмови, а силою своїх дій. Сміливістю та пращею.
Сміливість у нас є. Її достатньо. Не лише в України, а й в усієї нашої коаліції перемоги.
Праща має стати сильнішою.
Вже зараз. Щоб уже наступного року ми з вами тут, у Мюнхені,
зібралися на першу безпекову повоєнну конференцію.
За умови вільної України. Вільної Європи. І вільного світу.
Олафе, Еммануелю, усі наші друзі! Я думаю, ви мене зрозуміли.
Я дякую за увагу!
Ви – Давиди вільного світу!
Ми, об'єднані Давиди, переможемо путіних, розкиданих по всьому світу!
Слава кожному й кожній, хто зараз у бою!
Слава Україні!